She-Hulk smashed it with all those cool
cameos in season one but the final guest
spot might just be the most exciting
here's why season one of She-Hulk
attorney at law featured several
appearances from characters across the
Marvel Cinematic Universe from the Hulk
to Wong to Daredevil I just want to make
sure that you don't think this is one of
those Cameo every week type of shows
that hasn't been something that fans
have been complaining about though as
many tuned in to She-Hulk specifically
to see Daredevil in action since his
appearance was teased in an early
trailer for the show entire threads on
the Marvel Studios subreddit were
dedicated to discussing when The Man
Without Fear would finally show up in a
marvel.com interview with the show's
Creator Jessica GAO she talks about how
thrilled she was to be allowed to use a
character like Daredevil after all Matt
Murdock is no stranger to the courtroom
or the superhero lifestyle GAO explained
it just made so much sense that he would
be on this show because both he and Jen
are lawyers by day superheroes outside
side of the office even though Jen is
doing it reluctantly what better
character to kind of show how this
struggle she's having is possible but
while Daredevil may have been the focus
of many fans attention the character
casually introduced at the end of the
She-Hulk attorney at law season one
finale might be an even bigger deal at
the end of the finale Jen Walters her
family and Matt Murdock Relish in the
defeat of the conniving Intelligentsia
group unexpectedly Bruce Banner who
spent much of the series in space for
unknown reasons shows up at the family
Barbecue to introduce his son scar he
appears only briefly and doesn't have
any lines but it still opens the door
for this character to enter the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in the comic scar was
canonically introduced in World War Hulk
number five as part of the plotline
where Hulk was banished to the planet of
sakar Hulk conceived scar with Kaira the
old strong and the child matured very
quickly Becoming a Teen in just one year
in addition to have having his father's
Powers scar also has his mother's
abilities known as old Powers which
include being able to control and
manipulate the Earth itself it's notable
that Hulk has already spent time on
zakar in the MCU after Thor found him
there where he had been spending years
in the Hulk form fighting in tournaments
held by the Grand Master not much is
explained in the brief scene introducing
scarf but Bruce says he made a return
trip to the trash Planet I know I've
been away at the car for a while fans on
Reddit were already excited about the
opportunities that Scar's introduction
makes possible one posted I just hope
we'll know more about what happened to
Bruce on zakar in another series slash
movie others shared concerns about the
character's design with one fan posting
can I just say that scar looks off not
referring to CGI just doesn't look like
scar and looks like a honked up space
team and not the warrior if Marvel
decides to redesign the character for
future appearances it would hardly be
the first time that happened but
misgivings aside it's likely that scar
will appear again in the future
[Music]